I was homeless for two and a half years
and the problem with most of you you
never felt no pain before you're spoiled
y'all spoiled some of y'all spoiled just
bottom line your parents have done
everything for you you never have to do
nothing for yourself you're spoiled
we're gonna keep it real tonight some of
you are spoiled brats every time you
ever got in trouble somebody in your
house got you out of it every time
you've done something you're not
supposed to do people say Eric your
mother's retiring you're right she
kicked me out you're right she's mean
but she developed a man because she put
me out there and said you're gonna have
to grow up and some of you have never
learned to grow up